- C'est dans cet immeuble que
Jean-François Bélanger a acheté
sococondo il y a trois ans,
sa première propriété,
un gros investissement.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS BÉLANGER
- Oui, j'ai étiré l'élastique
au maximum. J'étais
inconfortable au tout début.
- Même s'il a contracté
une hypothèque à taux variable,
il ne craint pas trop
les hausses de taux d'intérêt
qui pointent à l'horizon.
- J'ai moins d'inquiétudes,
surtout sachant que
mes versements vont rester
les mêmes. C'est juste
que malheureusement, évidemment,
il y aura plus d'intérêt que de
capital qui va être remboursé.
- Mais d'autres pourraient
être pris au dépourvu si
leurs paiements hypothécaires
grimpent du jour au lendemain.
DAVID POLIQUIN,
analyste financier agréé
- Comme l'immobilier a monté
beaucoup, ceux qui ont acheté
récemment et qui ont un peu
poussé la note, bien, c'est sûr
ququque là, le paiement mensuel,
il va arriver vite.
Il va arriver vite
puis il va faire mal.
- Depuis le début de
la pandémie, le taux directeur
de la Banque du Canada est au
plancher, à un quart de point,
pour stimuler l'économie.
MaMaMais 22 mois plus tard,
c'est un coup de frein
dont elle a besoin, puisque
l'inflation frise les 5 %,
du jamais-vu depuis
le début des années 90.
La banque centrale doit
donc relever ses taux.
On pourrait voir de trois
à cinq hausses dès cette année.
SÉBASTIEN McMAHON, économiste
en chef, iA Groupe financier
- C'est un sentier de
hausses, d d d d devrait
en avoir plusieurs. On pense pas
que c'est pas une catastrophe
économique qui nous guette.
C'est juste une normalisation
de la politique monétaire.
- La hausse des taux d'intérêt
a pour objectif de réduire
la demanr r r r les biens
et services, ce qui devrait en
retour faire baisser les prix.
C'est un geste qui
pourrait bénéficier à ceux
qui sont durement touchés par
l'inflation, comme les retraités
qui ont des revenus fixes
et tous les autres qui doivents.
- Je vais probablement
avoir à refaire mon budget,
à revoir mes recettes,
mes dépenses, les loisir
également.
- D'autres facteurs pourraient
aussi contribuer à la réduction
des pressions inflationnistes.
HENDRIX VACHON, économiste
principal, Mouvement Desjardins
- On s'attend à ce que
les entreprises puissent
de mieeueueueueux produire
à plus faible coût, qu'il y ait
moins de problèmes de chaînes
d'approvisionnement, moins
de contraintes au jour le jour
en lien avec la pandémie.
Donc, on mise beaucoup
sur ces effets-là pour
réduire l'inflation.- - - - - -a
s'adonner à un exercice
d'équilibriste dans
un climat d'incertitude.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréa